winona ryder i've been married to keanu
reeves since we started in 1992's
dracula are you and winona ryder
technically married
keanu reeves is opening up about his
life and career as he graces the cover
of esquire and honestly he looks really
good the 57 year old actor touched on
many topics including the ongoing joke
that he and wynonna ryder are
technically married we did a whole take
of a marriage ceremony with real priests
so i guess we're married
under the eyes of god
now wynonna ryder wasn't the only former
co-star talked about in reeves esquire
issue the magazine caught up with his
speed co-star sandra bullock who was
asked whether her and keanu were ever
more than just friends
and quickly put those rumors to rest
sadly for all of us she said nope but
who knows ken is a guy who i feel like
is friends with every woman he's ever
dated i don't think there's anyone who
has something horrible to say about him
piano also talked about the impact of
playing the role of neo in the matrix
series it changed my life and it was
such a wonderful creative experience and
so to play neo in the matrix trilogy and
now in the fourth it impacted my life
personally and creatively
but what has fans really excited is
canon's interest in joining the marvel
cinematic universe in the future it
would be an honor there's
some really amazing directors and
visionaries and you know they're doing
something no one's really ever done it's
special in that sense in terms of the
scale
the ambition the production so it would
be cool to be a part of that okay now
this is my favorite part of the
interview it's when keanu was asked to
name three movies he'd recommend to
someone who's never heard of him before
and considering he's been in over 68
films in less than 35 years it's pretty
hard to narrow it down but reeves rose
to the challenge so his pick the matrix
and when i say the matrix let's do the
trilogy that's one then let's do the
devil's advocate and then let's do
we need something actiony in there so
let's do point break
you